you had already talked about what
happened you know with your
you know the the health issue yeah but i
just i
as someone that i never want to ask
something that anyone else has asked in
an interview or that you've asked talked
about so much
but now i feel the need to talk about it
again is you know uh correct me if i'm
wrong you were diagnosed with tongue
cancer yeah uh they said we're gonna
have to cut out 75 of it yep you said no
i'm gonna get some second opinions you
found this incredible person yep and
then you
lost
your taste from the chemo and then got
it back right for a year it was fun
already already amazing but i want to
just revisit that again because after
coved all of a sudden you know that's a
story that's already wild it's like a
chef loss of sensitivity yeah yeah at
what point are you like
all right god i get i get where you're
like
did it have anything to do with being a
chef and taste like or was that just a
total
crazy coincidence crazy for instance
never
no risk factors no that's like it's a
comedian you're getting cancer in my
wrist right holding my phone right never
smoked never drink heavily never you
know no nothing
no heavy kind of linguist no hpv they
had no idea where it came from and so
now
i feel like it's worth revisiting that
and talking to you because you know the
big thing about kovad was you lose your
taste yeah
and there was this
huge zeitgeist thing
where
all of a sudden there was a whole new
yeah appreciation for your tastes right
i i guess people don't realize we've all
probably had the flu and you know you're
eating your chicken soup you can't taste
it right
the phobia's name really brought it to
the forefront
um
i apparently never had cloven
really i i feel like karmic like you
played your dues in the department we'll
spare him on this round he's already
lost his taste yeah let's not be
assholes about it right
yeah so you know was it weird to hear
people complaining about that after
no no i was supposed to i mean you have
no motivation to eat yeah right yeah
even though you have to do it survive
if you're fantastic it's just like
but there's also something
you know miraculous that happens when
you lose one sense so i had covered and
i lost
both basically most of my
brain you guys saw the podcast pandemic
i got like the brain fog and i couldn't
remember things i lost my taste and
smell but it is kind of amazing
the like did you find there was any
magic in the other senses that got
stronger as you lacked that and were
building up i definitely paid attention
to the other senses to make up for it
yeah i don't know that they got
heightened i just paid attention to them
you know so interesting i would listen
to food
sounds a little weird wow yeah
i know but you know i've spent my whole
life pushing so when you put something
in a saute pan yeah
i know
by the way the oil is popping if the
pan's hot enough if it's ready to be
flipped if it you know
so you really start paying attention to
that stuff
[Music]
wow
[Applause]